والمنقوشه عند فرن ابو الديب بالف ليره
فقط ما هي الحكايه يا رينا
على هيك فرن ابو ديب يعني دائما بكون في
عنده كتير
كتير
رواد ومريدين
والمنقوشه سخنه يلا
انا اليوم بوسط
اسواق تعبيه وتحديدا في سوق العطارين هذا
سوق يلي بينتوي على الف قصه وقصه ولكن نحن
اليوم كما ذكرتم من اجل هنا من اجل افران
ايام زمان هذا الفرن مش لانه
من عمر المدينه انما لانه صاحبه يصير حتى
اليوم على بيع المنقوشه بالف ليره لبنانيه
فقط ورغيف الخبز ايضا يعني اليوم
اذا بدكن
اذا بدك بعمليه حسابيه سريعه يعني هو
يحتاج تبيع 100 منقوشه ليحصل دولار مش
ليكسب دولار يا بالتالي هو هو نفسه لا
يريد ان يدخل بعمليه الربح والخساره لانه
يقول انه هذا المرحله مش مرحله جمع ثروات
وتعبئه جيوب هي مرحله للوقوف الى جانب
الناس وخاصه في هذه المدينه يعني اللي
بتنعكس فيها الازمه بشكل مباشر كونه جزء
كبير من ابناء هذه المدينه يعيشون تحت خط
الفقر هنا خلفي يعني ومع تقدم ساعات
النهار ااا يتزايد التهافت على هذا الفرن
الذي ينتج المناقش والارغفه الخبز على
دفعات ويصل انتاج هذا الفرن الى اكثر
منقوشه ورغيفه حسب ما يقول الحاج ابي ذيب
الذي يشرف على هذا الفرن والذي يقول انه
يفضل الاقفال على تغليه على رفع سعر
التعرف اذا يعني المنقوشه هي وكما تعلمون
الترويقه المفضله لدى اللبنانيين ولكن هنا
في هذا الفرن لنجد سوى منقوشه الزعتر يعني
احنا لانهم صعب انه نوصلك يارينا ونتذوق
طبعا هذه المنقوشه اللي اكيد راح تكون
مميزه جدا
يا راويه منقوشه على الحطب مثل الموجوده
هون لانه الافران الحديثه بدوقيها عنا
التي
تنتج هذه المنقوشه هنا ولكن لصعوبه
الارسال في الداخل كون هي اغبياء واناظر
لا يمكننا الدخول مع الارسال خوفا من
تقطعه
زعتر مع جبنه احبها والله وخفيفه
راحت حتى خلاص خليها زعتر
طيب
[موسيقى]
ما اقول بانه طيب يعني بكلمتين كيف من
الممكن ان يصمد هذا الفرن اذا استمر بهذا
الحال
كيف يمكن ان يستمر بهذا الحل هذا هو سؤالك
عادل
اذا قاعدين يبيع المنقوشه بالف يعني
نعم نعم عم اقول لك يعني هو اكيد مش عامل
حساب ربح وخساره هو بالنسبه له هيدي
مبادره للوقوف الى الى جانب الناس وهيدي
طريقته لانه المنقوشه بالخارج تبع بين 40
الف ليره و90 الف ليره حسب المناطق وحسب
الافران فهو بالتالي يعمل هنا مع ابنائه
ومع عدد كبير من عائلته وينتج عدد كبير
جدا من المناقيش وهو يقول ايضا في هذا
السياق الفتره هي التي تجلب الخير وهو
الذي لا يريد ان يحرم الناس وخاصه تلاميذ
المدارس الذي الذين كنت اشاهدهم قبل قليل
يتزودون بمنقوش صغيره قبل ما يروحوا على
المدرسه تحياتنا له تحياتنا يعني واصيلنا
التحيات شكرا يا رينا يعطيك العافيه يا
رينادويهي يعطيك الف عافيه وصحتين
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات